це Оксана погомій якщо хтось ще досі не
знає це наша суперкрота Херсонська
активістка яка пережила окупацію і
дуже-дуже сильно допомагала всім із
заслужена
зараз оксанчик Розкажи що там коїться
зараз що у вас Херсон зараз що в нас в
Херсоні у нас так е-е було була
катастрофа на ГЕС після цього зараз ми
уже чекаємо І вже уже вона є ця
екологічна катастрофа але про це ж ніхто
не каже вони вже всі гарно У нас все
спокійно груші нам не треба Нам нічого
не треба вона взагалі все пучком е-е
пресу не допускають щоб вони не дивилися
що там уже мухи опаришився гніє кажуть
що нам нічого не потрібно вміст А нам
потрібні робочі руки але зазивати тому
що багато людей похилили віку залишилися
і вони не можуть самі своїми силами Там
просто і здамов треба викидати все це з
тих домівок котрі не посипалися вообще
взагалі людей виселили у кого нема куди
в шелтери якісь хтось не хоче кидати
свою домівку вони там залишаються сморід
просто жутки трупний запах запах Тіни
оце все на тих вулицях що були
розтоплені А є у нас наприклад
мікрорайону острів котрий був
підтоплений перший поверх півтора
поверха самі багатоповерхівки Але там є
дві багатоповерхівки 16 І поверхівки
вони з електроплитами їм Сказали що їм
світло
включать Ну можливо в вересні
і я розумію чому люди не хочуть
виїжджати Ми чекаємо що лівий берег з
їдять і я розумію що вони не хочуть
кидати те що нажити я колись бабушку
перевозила вона мені казала Ти що робиш
Ти що все на сміх не викидаєш я 60
відпила отак і тут люди взагалі основна
маса людей ті що залишилися в Херсоні -
це ті хто потребує допомоги насправді не
їсти їм треба робочі руки їм треба дати
дати якусь одежу потому що ви не от в
чому були в тому вони і спаслись
кому класно У нас зараз Це правда це
тваринка всі їх люблять корма везуть всі
везуть корми і це круто тваринки вже ото
того голубя которые здох вони не
підбирають ні ну правда Я кажу як є але
для людей зараз і ще у нас пам'ятаєте Як
тільки ви приїжджали як тільки було
підтоплення Да і тоді була проблема вода
так і зараз вона знову проблема вода
тому що у нас у нас тут жарко одно у вас
тут це Зелена А у нас тут все що у вас
зелене у нас це вже жовтень У нас дуже
жарко У нас військовим не вистачає води
вони просять у нас вона вже вона
закінчується то я буду просити щоб нам
хто може везіть нам воду ми будемо її
брати тому що спочатку ми розвозили от
ті кобижчі Петро Олексійович дуже
складно було розвозити просто Тому що
нема транспорту Ну от такий у нас Ну так
Вот так Ми зараз живемо нема знайти
навіть машину на котрому погрузили ні за
гроші не за великі гроші ні за якими
тому що бояться водії да да бояться їх
практично ті хто залишилися то у нас є
наш Руслану Котра година велика машина
була Ми по одному кубу возили то в село
то військові у нас забирали а от такий
баклажках було би гарно тому що просто
зараз не вистачає води я запитувала
сьогодні
вчора позавчора сьогодні
дві військові ну об'єднання звернулися Я
кажу вам вам не дають воду или вам
просто не вистачає вони кажуть нам не
вистачає ну правда дуже В окопах сидить
Я не уявляю зараз А що такое скільки там
їм виділяють Я навіть не знаю то оце у
нас зараз першочергова вода і робочі
руки Ну тут я не можу змушувати людей
щоб вони приїжджали під обстріл або
стріляють собаки тільки ксюню в Херсоні
дивилися вчора самі вільнюскі
Я була в дорозі
хочеться орать
хочеться рвати метать Мені соромно от я
не обирала но мені соромно правда Ярину
чому так ну чому мені мені завжди
приходиться червоніти не тільки мені От
соромно за те що
нема обличчя котре бы нас представляла
гідна що нема людини котра два слова
могла би зв'язати я не знаю хто там
тіпломатах Ну вони ж вони нічого не
робили для України у мене таке відчуття
з
22 з 24
лютого 22-го року у мене відчуття що ми
перемагаємо Вопреки
от ми перемагаємо просто тому що
вони би нас і здали А ми йдемо вони би і
хотіли а ми йдемо і ми переможемо в
любому випадку я тут просто не те що я
оптимістка я це знаю але якою ціною
а от техніка За твоєю спиною хоча би
радив
ми коли заїхали Нарешті я це побачила Я
взагалі як вижу емблему оцю фон
Порошенка Брати по зброї до речі Коли
зустрічаємося з кимось із військових і
коли ми бачимо у них Брати по зброї а ми
кажемо А ми з права громад і все ми вже
ріднесенькі бо ми всі один одного знаємо
это крута техніка насправді
супер ксюнечка Скажи щось українцям
такого оптимістичного звідки херсонці
оптимізм черпають де береш ти сили ще
оце все робити І вірити в перемогу
Я хочу
щоб моя Україна
не на словах була квітуча не на словах
була вільна не на слова була центром
Європи і найкращою країною Європи тому
попереду багато роботи і я розумію що
тільки після перемоги
почнеться розвиток сильний але для цього
треба буде пахать пахать І пахать якщо я
зараз упаду ви стільки буду битися
головою обстену і ті хто поруч Ну а хто
тоді буде допомагати Зараз на жаль лінія
фронту через наш Херсон проходить Зараз
на жаль так але
звідки той оптимізм у нас лівий берег Ми
кожен день його бачимо і мені хочеться
туди Я представляю как уявляю як лівому
берегу хочеться до нас тому ми Отак і
черпаємо сили з того що ми я казала і
буду казати ми приречені на перемогу ми
просто на неї приречені для цього треба
багато від чого відмовитися Багато що
зробити
Вопреки всему Скажем так але ми
переможемо